I'm a really Zay girl that's my favorite
kind of wine I feel like a like a Kerry
Bradshaw and a budget you know
I've never met an astronaut did I call
you a blast or not I think Africa
I just wanted to find out what are your
feelings masculinity Can Be imprisoning
You Look At Me
well are you concerned about white
children telling this anti-work story it
is Generation knowledge a lot of the
stuff that we just kind of had to brush
off and they have a voice I don't want
to say more spiritual but we Are
Spiritual do you pray for someone after
you tackle them
in America you have had a level of
reparations you can talk about how much
life matters we still live in a society
where capitalism matters more what is
the difference between
being a leader I would like you to photo
this oh yes are you using my influence
or my leadership
that's what it's like to be loved and
respected
[Music]